a top Iranian Revolutionary Guard
commander is warning that Wednesday's
missile attack on a base hosting US
troops in Iraq is only the start of a
revenge operation that will continue
across the region
Ali Hodges adair says Iran strikes
weren't meant to kill soldiers but to
damage the American military machine
Iran is dismissing us calls to negotiate
following the assassination of Iranian
military commander customs Soleimani yes
president Donald Trump appeared to be
backing away from further military
confrontation with Iran on Wednesday but
he also announced fresh sanctions for
Tehran until it changes its behavior
Trump though is also facing opposition
at home where the votes set on Thursday
to limit the president's ability to
carry out further military action
against Iran well a White House
correspondent Kimberly Hollis is in
Washington DC will be speaking to her in
just a moment first though let's cross
to Dora Jabari who's in Tehran dorsa
this has been a critical time in Iran
and now we're hearing developments from
this Revolutionary Guard commander what
more does he have to say and why is this
significant well this is a man in charge
of the Revolutionary Guards aerospace
division he would have operated under
the direction of the head of the
Revolutionary Guards commander himself
who would have given the order to launch
these ballistic missiles onto the US
base in western Iraq this Brigadier
General Ali Hodja they gave a statement
in short while ago detailing the
operation the Iranians carried out by
launching 13 ballistic missiles onto
their inal as a US base in western Iraq
let's hear some of what he had to say in
herre catechin Iria the missile attack
conducted against the US military base
in fact was the beginning of a great
move that God willing we'll be
continuing well tour so we have been
hearing lots of de-escalation but what
chance does diplomacy really have
particularly after comments like this
there's very little hope of any kind of
rapprochement now given the
assassination and of the class I'm
selling money and now these missiles
that have been launched what was
important to note from the statement
that we just received from the
Revolutionary Guards is that Iran was
not after harming or killing US military
personnel by this attacker they carried
out their aim was to hit military
equipment at this US base and that is
what they did and he's dead this general
also said that the United States did not
respond the Iranians were expecting a
immediate response a military response
from the Americans but they did not do
anything and he said that that is why
the Americans should leave this region
that they should be prepared for more
attacks until they are prepared to
completely withdraw from the Middle East
that is something that we've heard from
all levels of the leadership here since
the assassination of us in soleimani and
now of course custom Soleimani is the
military commander at the center of all
of this his funerals have taken place
and there was a ceremony to commemorate
him today it just give us a sense of
what happens in Iran Dorson the official
mourning period for Qasem Soleimani has
ended but the grieving period clearly
has not the Supreme Leader himself
hosted a morning ceremony in his own
compound in Tehran where we saw him
accompanied by the highest levels of
governments the president Hassan rouhani
along side the head of the country's
judiciary and the man who has been
replaced who has replaced us in
Soleimani as the head of the COTS force
Esmail Connie was sitting next to the
Supreme Leader directly next to him on
his left so a very important gesture to
the international community that even
though Qasem Soleimani may no longer be
sitting next to the supreme leader his
replacement is very much there and he
himself Connie issued a statement saying
that his work will carry on the same
path as that of Qasem Soleimani
so there is a mood here that the more
period has officially ended but the
grief that the nation feels for this
general that is no longer with them
continues and this is why many analysts
here believe that this is something the
Iranians will not let go the
assassination of Qasem Soleimani has
really altered the course of history not
only in Iran but in this entire region
and that is why any kind of dialogue
with the United States now is seen as
completely out of the question in the
foreseeable future okay
Dorsett Jabari thank you so much for
bringing us up-to-date from the Iranian
capital